look everyone knows that this thing is a
disaster it feels like there's a
recession on the way supply chain gas
prices just the whole thing is just an
absolute mess uh but we do have a black
lesbian press secretary that's the most
important thing her name is corinne
jean-pierre and uh peter ducey who is a
rare journalist that i don't have to put
air quotes around uh he asked her about
uh inflation and what's going on outside
of our borders as well why is the
president saying that inflation is worse
everywhere but here
because what we have seen
across the globe first of all inflation
is a global challenge as we have said uh
it is uh it is it is
it is caused by uh
uh clearly um the pandemic this once in
a generation pandemic that we are coming
out of and also uh most recently uh the
war that uh that putin started in
ukraine that has caused inflation as we
look at food and as we look at gas
prices so if you look at globally other
countries
and if you look at where we are
economically when you think about the
group 7 the g7
we are in a much stronger place than we
are economically than than the rest and
also i did that globally though he says
that inflation is worse everywhere but
here that's not true u.s has worse
inflation than germany france japan
canada india italy saudi arabia
so why is he saying i think what we are
saying is that uh
when you talk about inflation it is a
global thing and it is not just about
the united states this is something that
everyone is feeling because of coming
out of once once in a lifetime pandemic
because of the war that russia has
started in ukraine
so i love her tell there which she does
all the time which is what we are saying
or what we are trying to say it's not
the truth it's just what we are trying
to convey to you uh to hide the truth
mostly uh jedidiah let me start with you
here uh she blames the pandemic remember
kovid that was a thing for a while and
she blames putin of course putin's war
no responsibility these people don't
seem to blame perhaps the printing of
all the money
yeah that was a that was an interesting
moment there he asked her questions
she's like
putin you're just vomiting out work
pandemic i mean it's a terrible job
listen to have to defend joe biden have
to get up there and lie every day for
joe biden who doesn't even know where he
is half the time not an easy job i'll
give her that the thing is people feel
this stuff so her sitting there and
saying oh inflation you know it's not
really a thing here it's it's more a
thing other places and trying to
invalidate what people's experience is
isn't going to work democrats always
love
to make people feel dumb like oh you're
dumb you don't know what's up they want
you to be dumb they hope you're dumb
because if you're not dumb you're not
going to vote for them but the reality
is that people have to don't people buy
stuff they go to the grocery store they
buy stuff for their kids they see those
prices going up so you're not going to
delude people with a ridiculous answer
like this and suddenly they're going to
say oh well she said it wasn't a big
deal so obviously it's not no that's
like saying oh gas prices aren't really
going up you go to the gas station you
fill up your tank you have eyes and ears
you're not brain dead they're relying on
you to be brain dead because if you're
not brain dead there is no way in hell
that you would vote for these people so
i feel a little bit bad for her i'm not
gonna lie uh not an easy job but come on
man people feel this stuff own up take
some responsibility for all the stuff
you did this is like saying oh you know
this is their this is their part two
dave of oh if you get the vaccine you
won't get coveted come on
enough with the lies time is up
jedediah i know you were always kind of
red-pilled or as long as i've known you
red pill but i think you were like
doubly red-pilled this morning uh liz to
to her point do you think anyone is
buying this nonsense i mean i get it
we're all somewhat like-minded so we can
see through this stuff we can explain it
honestly but do you think that anyone is
watching that and not making that
connection between the price at the pump
or when they go to home depot as i was
at yesterday and just buying two by
fours or literally anything that prices
are sometimes double triple if not more
do you think anyone's buying it
no and funny that you mentioned home
depot because literally when we're
sitting here my husband's at home depot
right now and his electronic receipt
just popped into my phone because it's
attached to my email address and the
price is just is astronomical that's the
thing it doesn't matter what your
ideology is when you go to the gas
station and it costs a hundred dollars a
week to fill up uh to fill up your car
to commute back and forth to work to
take your kids to soccer practice or
school it doesn't matter if you're a
republican or democrat the the takeaway
that i got from that video though i get
this like secondhand embarrassment for
karine jean-pierre because you know say
what you will about sake she was a lying
hack but at least she was good at it at
least she was skilled at it but karine
jean-pierre is like so relieved when she
can actually regurgitate one of these
answers without checking her binder
first when the answer she's like oh wait
i know that when i actually know the
talking point here um it's a pandemic
and it's putin there i got it um it
doesn't matter to her if it's the truth
it is of course false
there's a really interesting
organization called the organization for
economic cooperation and development it
actually is comprised of 37 democracies
around the country and and they compare
around the world i mean they compare
data on their economies to see like if a
trend is happening in germany or in the
united kingdom is it happening here is
this an isolated trend or is it a global
trend and according to this organization
the united states is facing inflation at
two times the rate of the other 30 or
the other 36 nations that are in this um
in this global cooperation group and so
to blame it on the pandemic and to blame
it on putin makes absolutely no sense
when the pandemic impacted the entire
globe and putin has impacted the entire
globe why would we in the united states
be facing double unless unless dave it
was because of joe biden's policies that
just impact us here
so john to that point even if it was the
war and putin and even if it was the
pandemic
and 18 other things that he could excuse
away is it not the job of the president
to respond to things like that well and
make sure that the ship doesn't sink
i mean it would be if he wasn't asleep
in uh delaware in his beach house look
every time which is where he is right
which is
tracy chapman of the white house her
identity politics are on the guiding
light of her appointment
all i can think of dave jedediah liz is
that seen in billy madison where the
principal says
everyone's dumb for having
to have a listen to the answer and they
treat us like we're idiots look i paid
6.20
a gallon for premium in boca raton
yesterday that same station was 50 cents
a gallon cheaper last week these are
astronomical
price increases and as jetta diane liz
note people are going to the supermarket
they're going to home depot they're
going to the gas station all the lies in
the world about putin and global
economic conditions
they're not they're not able to sell it